- [Ray] Principles for Success.
An Ultra Mini-Series Adventure
in 30 Minutes and in Eight Episodes.
Episode Eight- Struggle Well.
So far, I described how I learned
to confront my own realities, my problems,
my mistakes and weaknesses,
and how I surrounded myself with others
who could do things better than I could.
This was the most
effective way I discovered
for making great decisions.
(cheering)
This is not the normal way of being
but through this approach,
I became very successful.
And being successful enabled me
to meet extraordinarily successful people
and see how they think.
I've discovered that their
journeys were similar to mine.
You might not know it
but they all struggle
and they all have weaknesses.
That they all get around
by working with people
who see risks and opportunities
that they would miss.
Over time, I learned that by nature
most people's greatest
strengths are also connected
to their most significant weaknesses.
And striving hard for big things is bound
to lead you to painful falls.
It's just part of the process.
Such setbacks will test you.
They sort people.
Some think hard about what
caused their setbacks,
learned lessons, and continue progressing
toward their goals.
While others decide that
this game is not for them
and get off the field,
I've come to realize that success
is not a matter of attaining one's goals.
I found that when I reached
each new higher level of success,
I really remained satisfied.
The things we're striving
for are just the bait.
Struggling to get them
forces us to evolve.
And it is this struggle
to our personal evolution with
others that is the reward.
I no longer wanted to
get across the jungle
but instead wanted to find greater
and greater challenges to go after.
Surrounded by great
people working together
on a shared journey.
Eventually, the success of the mission
and the well-being of
the people alongside me
became more important than my own success.
I also started to see beyond myself
and wanted others to be successful
when I'm no longer here.
I realized that if I failed to do that,
I will be a failure.
I struggle with this now.
We all struggle with different
things at different times
until we either choose to
give up or until we die
and become part of the
larger evolutionary story.
This is how all machines work
and are recycled through time.
When a machine breaks down,
it's parts go back into the system
to become parts of new machines
that also evolved through time.
Sometimes this makes us sad
because we become very
attached to our machines.
But if you look at it from a higher level,
it's really beautiful to observe
how the machine of evolution works.
Now you must decide for
yourself how you will evolve.
Forget about where these
principles came from.
Just assess whether or
not they are useful to you
and evolve them to sooth your own needs.
As with all of life's decisions,
what you do with them
is ultimately up to you.
My only hope for you is
that you have the courage
to struggle and evolve
well to make your life
as great as it can be.
Thank you and goodbye.